nobody likes to make a mistake and I
made a whopping one and figuring out
what I did wrong
led to a discovery that completely
changes the way we think about the earth
and moon I'm a planetary scientist and
my favorite thing to do is smash planets
together in my lab I can shoot at rocks
using cannons like this one in my
experiments I can generate the extreme
conditions during planet formation and
with computer models I can collide whole
planets together to make them grow or I
can destroy them I want to understand
how to make the earth and the moon and
why the earth is so different from other
planets the leading idea for the origin
of the earth and moon is called the
giant impact theory the theory states
that a mars-sized body struck the young
earth and the moon formed from the
debris of discs around the debris disc
around the planet the theory can explain
so many things about the moon but it has
a huge flaw it predicts that the moon is
mostly made from the mars-sized planet
that the earth and the moon are made
from different materials but that's not
what we see the earth in the moon are
actually like identical twins the
genetic code of planets is written in
the isotopes of the elements the Earth's
and Moon have identical isotopes that
means that the Earth and Moon are made
from the same materials it's really
strange that the earth and the moon or
twins all of the planets are made from
different materials so they all have
different isotopes they all have their
own gender
at code no other planetary bodies have
the same genetic relationship only the
Earth and Moon are twins when I started
working on the origin of the moon there
were scientists that wanted to reject
the whole idea of the giant impact they
didn't see any way for this theory to
explain special relationship between the
earth and the moon
we were all trying to think of new ideas
the problem was there weren't any better
ideas all of the other ideas had even
bigger flaws so we were trying to rescue
the giant impact theory a young
scientist in my group suggested that we
try changing the spin of the giant
impact maybe making the earth spin
faster could mix more material and
explain the moon the mars-sized impactor
had been chosen because it could make
them in and make the length of Earth
stay people really liked that part of
the model but what is something else
determine the length of verse a day then
there would be many more possible giant
impacts that could make the moon I was
curious about what could happen so I
tried simulating faster spinning giant
impacts and I found that it is possible
to make a disk out of the same mixture
of materials as the planet we were
pretty excited maybe this was the way to
explain the moon the problem is we also
found that that's just not very likely
most of the time the disk is different
from the planet and it looked like
making our moon this way would be an
astronomical coincidence and it was just
hard for everyone to accept the idea
that the moon's special connection to
Earth was an accident the giant impact
theory was still in trouble and we were
still trying to figure out how to make
the moon then came the day when I
realized my
take my student and I were looking at
the data from these fast fitting giant
impacts on that day we weren't actually
thinking about the moon we were looking
at the planet the planet gets super hot
and partially vaporized from the energy
of the impact but the data didn't look
like a planet it looked really strange
the planet was weirdly connected to the
disk I got that super excited feeling
when something really wrong might be
something really interesting in all of
my calculations I had assumed there was
a planet with a separate disc around it
calculating what was in the disk was how
we tested whether an impact could make
the moon but it didn't look that simple
anymore we were making the mistake of
thinking that a planet was always going
to look like a planet on that day I knew
that a giant impact was making something
completely new I've had Eureka moments
this was not one of them it really
didn't know what was going on I had this
strange new object in front of me and
the challenge to try and figure it out
what do you do when faced with the
unknown how do you even start we
questioned everything what is the planet
when is a planet no longer a planet
anymore we played with new ideas we had
to get rid of our old way of thinking
and by playing I could throw away all of
the data all of the rules of the real
world and free my mind to explore and by
making a mental space where I could try
out outrageous ideas and then bring them
back into the real world to test them I
could learn
and by playing we learned so much I
combined my lab experiments with
computer models and discovered that
after most giant impacts the earth is so
hot there's no surface there's just a
deep layer of gas that gets denser and
denser with depth the earth would have
been like Jupiter there's nothing to
stand on and that was just part of the
problem I wanted to understand the whole
problem I couldn't let go of the
challenge to figure out what was really
going on in giant impacts it took almost
two years of throwing away old ideas and
building new ones that we understood the
data and knew what it meant for the moon
I discovered a new type of astronomical
object it's not a planet
it's made from planets a planet is a
body whose self gravity is strong enough
to give it its rounded shape it spins
around all together make it hotter and
spin it faster the equator gets bigger
and bigger until it reaches a tipping
point push past the tipping point and
the material at the equator spreads into
a disk it's now broken all the rules of
being a planet it can't spin around
together anymore
its shape keeps changing as it gets
bigger and bigger the planet has become
something new we gave our discovery its
name senesce Tia we named it after the
goddess Hestia the Greek goddess of the
hearth and home because we think the
earth became one the prefix means
altogether to emphasize the connection
between all of the material Acin Astia
is what a planet becomes when heat and
spin push it over the limit of a
spheroidal shape would you like to see a
senesce tia in this visualization of one
of my simulations the young earth is
already spinning quickly from a previous
giant impact its shape is deformed but
our planet would
be recognizable by the water on its
surface the energy from the impact they
per eise's the surface the water the
atmosphere and mixes all of the gases
together in just a few hours we
discovered that many giant impacts makes
the nest ia's but these burning bright
objects don't live very long they cool
down shrink and turn back into planets
while rocky planets like Earth were
growing they probably turned into Sun s
T as one or more times hacen asteya
gives us a new way to solve the problem
of the origin of the Moon we propose
that the moon formed inside a huge
vaporous Sonesta the moon grew from
magma rain that condensed out of the
rock vapor the moon's special connection
to earth is because the moon formed
inside the earth when earth was a
senesce Tiye the moon could have orbited
inside the Sun s Tiye for years hidden
from view the moon is revealed by the
Sonesta a cooling and shrinking inside
of its orbit the Sun s Tia turns into
planet Earth only after cooling for
hundreds of years longer in our new
theory the giant impact makes the Sun s
Tia and the Sun s Tia divides into two
new bodies creating our isotopically
identical earth and moon Sun s Tia's
have been created throughout the
universe and we only just realized that
by finding them in our imagination what
else am I missing in the world around me
what is hidden from my view by my own
assumptions the next time you look at
the moon remember the things you think
you know
maybe the opportunity to discover
something truly amazing
[Applause]
[Music]